So in the second volume of Harry Potter,
correct me if I have any of these
details,
rog.
You remember?
There's that snake,
the bast lisc.
So this is magic castle,
right?
You guys have no problem with that magic
castle.
No problem.
There's a north,
he's an orphan.
He goes to the magic castle to learn how
to be more than normal,
right?
The muggles,
he has a muggle family,
were not too happy with the muggle
family,
like as representatives of normal
people.
They,
they have some blacks now.
Of course,
the reason for that is that,
well,
that's what teenagers often feel about
their parents,
right?
They failed Jesus.
These couldn't really be my parents.
I must have some other parents who were
like together knows it,
like magical parents,
right?
Parents that live in the sky.
And of course Harry Potter has earthly
parents.
That's the muggles.
And Dursley I think is the kid.
He's a one.
He's a wonderful piece of work and uh,
you know,
ill formed day,
spoiled,
ill formed,
selfish very far from the ideal.
He's a foil for Harry.
And of course he's appreciated and doted
on.
And Harry is actually punished for his
virtues.
Lots of classic story,
right?
To be punished for your virtues.
I mean if you look at the story,
the central story in Christianity,
the central story in Christianity is
about someone who is precisely punished
in the worst possible way for the
highest possible virtues.
That's what it makes it an archetypal
story because there isn't anything more
unfair than that.
And so it's a limit in a sense.
You can't be worse than that.
Being punished for being,
you know,
unworthy.
It's like,
yeah,
I will at least make sense,
but to be punished because you have your
act together and you're a good person.
That's real punishment.
And that's what happens to Harry.
So luckily he finds out that he's
magical,
which is quite convenient.
And off he goes to wizarding school and
you know,
that's actually like taking.
That's actually like going and studying
the humanities.
I mean it was when they still were.
No,
because it's through the humanities that
you,
that you make contact with the magic of
your culture and that makes you more
than merely the child of your parents
because you are more than merely the
child of your parents.
You're the child of nature and you're
the child of culture,
and until you understand what that
means,
understand that you have two sets of
parents,
like the divine hero always has two sets
of parents.
You can't construe yourself properly as
an individual.
You're not situated properly in the
world.
You don't know what your
responsibilities are.
You can't orient your values properly
and you will suffer for that because as
far as I can tell,
because life is so difficult,
you have to do something that's truly
worthwhile in order to justify it,
and so while that's what these stories
tell you,
that's what the story of Jonah is
telling you.
It's like you have an ethical duty to
straighten things up and if you don't do
it,
you're going to be story.
And that story is echoed everywhere.
Well now,
St George.
Well,
let's go to Harry Potter.
That's what we were talking about.
So he goes off to the magic castle and
uh,
he's learning to be a wizard and he's
kind of an interesting character because
he's not really good and we find out
what I think that's because it doesn't
have a piece of Volta,
Marty and um,
he's not what happens.
Yeah.
And that's what that means is that to be
good,
truly good,
you kind of just follow rules that's
very clear in the Harry Potter story and
you also have to be able to understand
malevolence and in order to understand
malevolence so that you can withstand
it,
you have to understand that part of you
that's malevolent because if you don't,
you're naive.
If you're naive,
you're easy pickings.
And so that's a union idea too.
And the union idea is that part of
personality development is to understand
your shadow and the shadow is those
things about you that you do not want to
admit to.
And
you can learn about your shadow by
reading history.
You know,
you can read about Auschwitz,
you can read about the concentration
camps in Russia and you can imagine
yourself as a guard instead of as a
heroic rescue or unfortunate victims,
which would be very,
very unlikely and once you can imagine
yourself as a guard,
which is a terrifying thing to do,
then you understand something about
yourself.
And I actually think,
and I think this is also from student
studying young,
that you cannot have proper respect for
yourself until you know that you're a
monster because you won't act carefully
enough.
You know,
if you think,
well,
I'm a nice person.
I'd never do anyone any harm.
It's like,
you know,
St you can be sure of that and the harm
that you do.
People can come in many,
many ways and so if you regard yourself
as harmless,
inoffensive,
nice.
Well Marty,
you have any reason to be careful.
You're like a teddy bear sitting on a
shelf.
Even if you throw it at someone,
no one's going to get hurt,
but that isn't what you're like because
you're a human being and human beings
are some vicious creatures and there's
utility in knowing that because it's
also the case.
You know,
when the Harry Potter series,
Harry could stand up against voldemort
and understand them and speak his
language because he was infected by him
to some degree.
Very,
very interesting idea.
Anyways,
in the second 10,
the reason I'm telling you this,
and this is where thinking about,
it's like how long were each of those
books?
Like 500 pages long and there was how
many of them?
Seven and how many of them were sold.
I mean,
how many of you read every Harry Potter
book,
right?
Absolutely.
How many of you read at least one?
Okay.
How many of you saw the movies?
It's like you're all in a cult.
You are.
I'm telling you.
Really,
that's the truth.
It's really the truth.
So in the second volume,
there's this snake that zipping around
there,
the Basilisk,
right?
And it lives in the underground.
That's chaos.
And that's because wherever you are,
you're on thin ice and underneath your
thin ice is chaos.
And here we are in this unbelievably
civilized environment and everyone's
getting along so perfectly.
But you know,
we've got hot,
we've got lights,
we've got electricity,
sewage system is working,
no one's hungry.
It's like we can be peaceful,
but if any of that fell apart and it
could easily fall apart because it's a
bloody miracle it ever works at all,
then the chaos that's just underneath
the surface is going to come up and
right now.
And it's useful to know that because it
makes you properly grateful.
If you really understand it,
it makes you properly grateful for the
bloody miracle it is that you can be
here in peace.
So anyways,
there's this snake that's underneath the
surface and it's no joke that thing.
It's big and it's ancient.
It's always been there.
And what happens if you look at it,
it turns you to stone,
right?
It paralyzes you.
Well,
that's the,
that's the Gorgon,
that's Medusa.
The woman with the head of snakes.
And if you look at her,
it paralyzes you.
What does that mean?
Well,
you're walking through the jungle and
big snake appears.
What do you do?
You freeze and no bloody wonder because
you're a prey animal and that's what
they do when they see things that are
going to eat them,
and so the snake,
well,
lots of people still die from snakebite
and our ancestors were our ancestors
like you know,
tens of millions of years ago when they
were living in trees and weren't very
big,
they made a nice snack for a snake and
there's a woman named Lynn Isabelle,
who's an anthropologist at Ucla who's
correlated the presence of carnivorous
snakes with the acuity of primate
vision.
And what she found was that the more
snakes around the better the primates
could see.
So and we're particularly good at
picking up patterns like snake
camouflage in the lower half of our
visual quadrant.
You know,
when people generally don't like snakes,
you can learn to handle them,
but no snake.
Fear appears to be innate.
It's innate in chimpanzees and it tends
to increase as you age than decreasing.
You can overcome it,
but.
Well,
my daughter had snakes and one day her
sneak bitter.
It was a fairly big snake
and she hadn't paid attention to it for
awhile.
So it nailed her.
And from then on she had had very
difficult time grabbing the snake,
bitten once shy permanently.
She also told me years later she had
nightmares about snakes all the time
when she had a snake in her room.
It's like,
you know,
and I think it was probably the smell.
So anyways,
so Harry Potter decides he's going to go
after the basilisk Greg,
he's going to go out there and face the
thing that he's most afraid of.
So he does that.
Weighed out in the depths.
So it's like Jonah going down into the
depths and he faces the basilisk and it
bites him and you know,
that's uh,
that's right.
Because if you go down into the depths,
you can get bitten.
Like it's no joke,
and this is a hero story,
but the thing about the hero stories,
it's actually real.
The thing that you're facing is actually
dangerous.
And even though facing it voluntarily
might be your best bet and is likely
your best bet,
because that's the central story of
humanity,
that doesn't mean you're going to
succeed.
It's the real thing.
So anyways,
he gets bitten,
right?
And he's going to die.
Now he's rescuing Jenny.
So that's the St George Story.
If you go after like dragon dragons,
like to capture virgins,
God only knows why I think it's because
I think it's because one of the things
that male humans have done from the
beginning of time is chase the damn
predators away.
And I suspect that the males from God
only knows how long ago who were
particularly good at that we're rewarded
with female attention.
And why the hell not so?
It's deeply rooted inside of us.
That idea of facing the unknown and
freeing the woman.
So the idea there is that if you.
It's a male idea,
and in large part I can talk about the
central female myth and I will as we
proceed.
The idea is that if you're the sort of
person who can stand up against the
unknown and the frightening,
then you're also likely if you develop
into that sort of person,
then you're also likely to develop into
the sort of person that other people
will find attractive.
So you know,
and that's why young believed that the
inside the shadow was the anima,
which is like a female figure.
And so his idea was something like,
you know,
if you look watch movies,
there's always this Beta male guy,
if they're romantic movies and he's a
nice guy and he's the friend and you
know,
the woman tells them everything but she
doesn't like him a bit.
She likes the guy who's like got an edge
and who's capable of,
I would say mayhem,
but at least have aggression.
Now,
that doesn't mean she wants him to be
aggressive,
but what it does mean is that she wants
him to be able to be aggressive.
That would be good.
And so he's the romantic target and so
he's the person that's incorporating the
shadow and he's someone that is
respectable and perhaps useful.
And so.
Well,
that's a very old story,
so let's,
let's think about this for a minute.
I've already offered you a proposition
and I think it's an important
proposition and I'm offering you this
proposition so that you can make sense
of art and literature and mythology and
religion and dance and all those strange
ritualistic things that human beings do,
which seems central to us,
including including not least,
the ineradicable tendency of us to seek
out stories of heroes.
I should finish the Harry Potter story.
So Harry Potter goes down there to
rescue Virginia.
No,
it's,
that's not her name.
What is it,
Jenny?
Yeah,
but there's a,
there's a formal name for that.
It's a variant of Virginia anyways,
which is very divergent.
So,
um,
and he gets bitten.
Jen.
Yes.
Ginevra.
That's it.
He gets bitten and the bite is poisonous
and so there is dying,
which doesn't seem to be so good.
And then what happens?
And again,
you guys swallowed this.
It's no problem.
So what's his name?
The dumbledore character.
He's got a bird,
right?
So he's the wise old man.
He's the ruler of the castle.
He's the ruler of the magic castle.
He's the magic king,
you know,
he's like,
God the father as far as Harry Potter is
concerned,
and he has a bird.
What kind of bird is it?
It's a phoenix.
Right?
And one of the things that's very
strange about a phoenix is that while
it's a mortal but in a strange way,
you know,
it lives and lives,
I think 100 years and it gets older and
older and then one day poof,
it burst into flames and turns into an
egg and then you get a new phoenix.
So that's a symbol of transformation.
It's a symbol of transformation.
The bird is a spirit or psyche,
and so here's what it means in part,
you know,
you know how when you learn a lesson in
your life that that's not very pleasant,
right?
It's not like when you learn something
important,
it's the best day of your life.
It's often the importance of what you
learn is often proportionate to just how
ratcheted it is to learn it.
You know,
you learn things the hard way.
You learn things by getting hit because
obviously if what you're doing is
working,
you get what you want.
There's no learning in that and that's
happy.
It's when you're doing something and you
hit an obstacle and maybe a bloody well
hit it hard and then you know you recoil
and then you down into the depths you go
and you have to sort yourself out and he
realized that you're,
you know,
this particular kind of idiot and that
you should probably fix that and that's
really annoying and difficult and you
know,
and maybe you're down in the dumps and
anxious for quite a while and then you
get it repaired more or less than you
know,
you put yourself back together.
That's the Phoenix poof into flames.
Bang Egg knew you.
And so you know,
that's the ability to learn.
Human beings are very strange creatures,
right?
Because we're very malleable compared to
most animals,
like grizzly bears now in grizzly bears
a thousand years ago.
It's like whatever.
They are the same thing.
They do the same thing.
There was no transformation about human
beings.
We have this massive brain and you know,
it's a pain because it means you have to
take care of human children until
they're 40 and that's a big burden and
so,
you know,
we pay a big price for it.
It also makes childbirth very difficult
and uh,
and it's costly.
You have to eat a lot because you have a
big brain because it uses up a lot of
energy and so,
you know,
you pay a price for it,
but the advantages your plastic you can
learn.
Now learning is a strange thing because
you can think of it as just acquiring
more information,
but you could also think of it and this
is more accurate as finding out
something that you're doing wrong.
So that sort of built into you like a
character,
a character element of your character,
of presumption,
of your perception or a deep habit.
It's really built into you.
It's a neural structure,
right?
It's little,
it's alive and you have to kill it
because he's working properly.
And the pain that you go through in part
when you're suffering because you did
something stupid.
Is it something like your,
your,
the neurology,
I can never get this quite right.
It's the pain of the death of that
structure and that can be a huge chunk
of you.
You know,
if,
if you really have to go through a
massive revision,
it's like the person that comes out the
other end might hardly be the same at
all.
You know?
That happens.
For example,
if you're trying to combat alcoholism,
which is just,
you know,
a wretched thing to do because,
well,
all your friends are alcoholic.
All your family drinks too much.
The only thing you know how to do when
you're socializing is to go to the bar
and drink too much.
You know when you spend like 20 hours a
week on it,
it's like it's not just that you're
addicted to the substance.
It's like that's how you live.
And so if you want to stop being an
alcoholic,
not only do you have to stop drinking
alcohol,
but you have to stop seeing all your
drunk friends and then maybe you've had
them for your whole life and you have to
have continual battles with your drunk
family.
And then you have to figure out
something to do with that 20 hours.
It's now like hanging around your neck
like an Albatross,
and so you have to let that whole part
of your personality die and a new part
has to spring forth.
And that's what the Phoenix is.
And the Phoenix is the capacity of the
person to transform.
And so when Harry gets bit by the snake
that freezes him,
he gets seriously injured.
The Phoenix comes in Christ,
some tears in his wound,
it prepares him,
Bang.
He's back to life.
And
the strange thing is that that's okay
with all of the viewers.
Now why would that be?
There's nothing about it that's
rational.
Nothing,
right?
Magic Castle.
That's not rational.
Giant snake underneath it.
That's a little more rational turning
you to stone going down there to face
it,
being rejuvenated by a phoenix.
It's like,
yeah,
that's okay.
We can.
We'll watch that.
We'll swallow it will be completely
engaged in it.
And the reason for that is because it's
a myth.
It's about how people.
It's a Meta story about how to act about
how to conduct yourself.
In the world to face the things that
you're afraid of that would otherwise
paralyze you,
to let the death of what is insufficient
about you or occur and then to wait for
the rebirth.